qué hace desde un punto de vista
meteorológico que una tormenta grace en
este caso se haya convertido en un
huracán
definitivamente como como tú dijiste que
se convirtió en huracán significa que
las condiciones estaban bien favorables
para que los vientos continuará
aumentando especialmente las aguas del
caribe que ya sabemos que son muy
calientes y que que pueden mantener ese
flujo de aire entrando y mantener esa
trayectoria de intensificación
estamos en un momento donde afloran
diferentes catástrofes naturales estamos
viendo en todo el hemisferio norte el
hemisferio sur en todas partes del
planeta incendios inundaciones huracanes
es el cambio climático un factor
determinante en todo esto no claro que
así el cambio climático es un cambio que
estamos viendo todos a través como tú
mismo y cs en distintas lugares del
planeta y si se han visto en los cambios
en lluvias donde donde en lugares que
llovía llueve más en lugares e incendios
hay mucho más desastres y en el caso de
los huracanes si se ha visto ese cambio
a través de los años así que
definitivamente
y si el cambio climático es responsable
qué podemos hacer nosotros y qué medidas
se tienen que tomar definitivamente los
países sobre todo en eeuu donde ustedes
reside durante esta próxima cumbre
climática de la onu en glasgow la cob 26
no es definitivamente es un trabajo de
cada uno personal y pensamos que después
de un cambio que alguien debe hacer pero
que cada uno puede empezar con un cambio
personal ya sea cambiar el utilizado en
el plástico o sea utilizar distintas
cosas que reciclar el material es
definitivamente un paso que debemos cada
uno como personas como ciudadanos porque
al fin y al cabo pues la tierra es de
todos nosotros así que definitivamente
un paso que debemos poco a poco para que
para lograr y para lograr poner nuestro
grano de arena definitivamente hace un
cambio hace un cambio grande pero
definitivamente estaremos vigilando la
entrada de grace y se esperan lluvias
torrenciales en esa área así que
definitivamente en la noche de hoy y
mañana tendrán necesaria fuerte desde
veracruz hasta puebla en vendrán esas
lluvias fuertes y necesarias y
precisamente estas zonas que se van a
ver afectadas en las próximas horas que
preparativos deberían tomar ante la
llegada de grace
si actualmente definitivamente deben
tener todos sus preparativos ya
cumplidos ir a arias donde no sean
inundables si necesita ir a refugios
llamados por los municipios locales que
definitivamente tomen la acción ahora
porque ya se espera que esta noche ya
los azotes del huracán y comiencen desde
las lluvias hasta marejada alta y el
viento fuerte así que definitivamente ha
a salir de los lugares de que se inunden
y es en lugares donde pueda el viento
esté más protegido pues muchísimas
gracias patricia sánchez meteoróloga del
servicio nacional de meteorología de
estados unidos por su información hoy en
france 24